have you ever considered quitting comedy
in your 30-year career I I want to hear
something dark yeah I'll tell you dark I
was going to ensure [__] of myself and
get myself to leave much money for my
wife really yeah like recently probably
within probably before the pandemic cuz
I I was just in a dark place I was just
in a dark place and I was like I was
about I'm 52 now so I was about to turn
50 or something like that I was like I
was stuck at this medium To Mediocre
I was I was
struggling to get work I was struggling
hot breath welcome back hot breath of
verse this is the show where you learn
comedy from the pros I'm your host
comedian Joel buers and our guest today
is coming back for a second round his
first time we had him on back in 2019 we
talked about his whole journey from
starting comedy back in 1994 all the
sacrifices that got him to where he was
at that point After hot breath he blows
up up on social media coincidence maybe
he got the hot breath bump here but all
that being said he actually blew up on
social media doing what he used to get
fired at shows for doing which is crowd
work and we're going to learn all about
it at 1:00 a.m. here in Atlanta Georgia
Ian bag welcome back to the hot breath
of Joel goodness see my
friend you just turned it on right there
I appreciate that sorry I didn't mean to
no you're good we you don't have to do
crowd work I was very quiet for a while
you're like oh God he going to be
horrible and then I said okay let's do
this come on Joel let's do this let's
make let's give the people what they
want I I I'm so grateful you did this
honestly it's it's 1:00 a.m. and you got
into town today and you just did two
shows so thank you we're just talking I
was just talking to a couple of the
waiters that do stand up at the club
about that and I said yeah my brain is a
little bit dead after a travel day and
two shows MH but uh I said I'll go see
Jewel we'll do a little bit of talking
and uh yeah and and uh yeah yeah it's
it's fun it's worth it yeah well I
appreciate you giving back to you know
us up and cominging Comics whatever you
bunch of
dues but congratulations dude like it I
don't I don't know when the moment
happened when you popped but like on
your YouTube it was about three months
ago when like videos started to take off
what what is what's happened here Ian
what what happened to you well um I'm
fantastic no that's what this is 30
years in the making is what I'm saying
you know people don't need to understand
in that part as well well the social
media thing is just is just
uh in October September October last
year I fired everybody I worked with
except for my booking agent huh and I
just kind of floundered for a bit and
but I knew that what I could
do I didn't need to be paying anybody
else to do right
so I and I just kind of started looking
around and I had a couple friends say
you need to meet this person so was a
kid that cut clip
that love standup that worked in a
social media house so I like all right
so I met him we met him I met him twice
and we ended up working together in
January 1st is when we started doing
work when we first started posting
things of this year of this year so on
January 1st I had 20,000 followers on
Instagram 5,000 followers on
YouTube um 20,000 followers on Facebook
and probably 2,000 followers on on uh on
Tik
Tok yeah so and now we're up to about
380,000 on Facebook uh about 195,000 on
on uh Instagram and 22,000 on YouTube
it's kind of crazy how how does it feel
after all the work you've put into this
feels a little surreal yeah it feels
really good like I I'm I'm not going to
lie I'm a little disappointed in the
numbers this week uh the numbers at the
people have been showing up the shows
have been packed selling out everywhere
and it's just been it's been insane so
it's been it's been really nice it just
it's just just fun it's just yeah fun
having these people show up to do what I
see what I do so yeah yeah well the
first show was sold out it seemed close
close I want both I
want I want all four sold out but that
that is that's the interesting
interesting thing about comedy and
that's why I wanted to come and watch
both shows before we did this one just
to see the shows and compare the two and
how different they are but then also of
like okay what does a comedian have to
do like you're blowing up like you said
you're selling out but then what is
where is the gap that the the The Late
Show you're still like H this is a late
show it's it's the markets it's it's uh
me me now having to learn how to sell
what I've sold online turn that into
ticket sales like right now I'm not
putting that much into marketing my
shows right so now I my next step is
marketing my shows so the people that
follow me and that see me are buying
tickets to see shows so that's the next
step and people are people are flying in
to see you yeah was that was crazy like
both shows both shows people flew in to
see you dude yeah s St Louis T coke uh
Florida Beach Florida Florida and then
Chicago was that was that what was St
Louis or you said St Louis St Louis some
someplace else I can't remember but I
was just like
huh huh okay so what when did you fire
everyone I'm sorry what year when did
you say well September October of last
year so
2022 oh my what what made you fire
everyone after the pandemic I
realized only you can create your own
destiny mhm and you only you
can um create the Heat
and what I've learned in the last year
is social media is giv
me the the ability to take my product to
the people without The Gatekeepers being
involved so in a weird way where I'm my
me and my people have found me outlying
so I'm an outlier whatever they call
right I'm not doing it the normal way
but I am because I'm using social media
and social media is helping me but those
people that you hire for managers
and and agents have to have something
that they can service I didn't have
anything for them to service so I was
paying them something that wasn't
helping my product build I took that
money that was that I was I was using on
them and put it into this kid cutting
clips and and helping me put stuff out
and that's what changed everything it's
just you literally just like oh I just
replaced the old basically industry
formula with a kid who can edit yeah
25-year-old kid that can edit and knows
when to tell me to put things up and
knows the social media like we're going
through something right now I'm Shadow
banned on on Instagram what happened um
I think I got into it with a couple
different people that were sending hate
and then they complained oh like they
instead of me just what you should do
and this is for everybody when somebody
sends you hate on social media instead
of going this guy's a douche and I know
they're douche and I'm going to call him
a douche or a baked potato or a useless
potato um just block them don't let them
see your content and move on just uh
mute them whatever you have to do just
move on you you don't win and if you
respond to them
they have they it's now you're
considered the bully even though
somebody's even though somebody's come
on to your onto your page and told you
and you know that they're going to kill
you they're going to kill your family
stuff like oh yeah I've had stuff like
that being said because they didn't
agree with jokes and and and you know I
was just like step up buddy you know
kind of thing so but you can't you can
play that game it's a game that you
can't play
and as a comedian as a a kid that played
team sports
I'm really good at retaliating and
retaliating gets you in trouble so you
have to do you just have to do you have
to deal with it and you just have to get
them out of your life by saying my stuff
is for the people that enjoy it not for
the people that want to complain or hate
it or whatever it's not for it's not for
them and there's so many more people
that like you than hate you so I've done
this learning for you so please take it
and enjoy it just just just delete
delete and destroy without touching them
so these people would say I want to kill
you and you were like bring it on yeah
like yeah and then they say something
and then I just turn it around on them
and was like and I would use certain
words that would upset them and I just
like no you gota you just go to you just
got to yeah yeah but I don't know
anybody I as I as I've leared over the
last six
months there's you're going to get those
people everybody gets those people it's
not just you and it's a weird thing cuz
you're you as a comedian you're used to
being able to disarm and destroy or get
somebody to that isn't enjoying
themselves to move on and with social
media it's tough you have to really you
have to you have to block them you have
to mute them you have to get rid of them
and it's a weird you know it's a I'm
going to sneeze in a second but I want
to sneeze but um go for it okay hold
maybe in a bit maybe look into the light
maybe that'll help trigger okay anyways
so so um do you just just you just got
to you you got you got to you got to CU
you're panicked right sorry I lost my
mind track there two shows had to sneeze
got lost where it was 1:30 in the
morning you have to you have
to you have to not take the high road
but you just can't it can't be part of
it you have to just dis make it
disappear and that's the only way and I
know I was going to say um Instagram uh
Facebook and I think even YouTube well
YouTube's even weirder you YouTube you
can't block people did you know that
uh-uh you can't block people they've
taken away the the ability to block
people oh interesting you can let them
not be able to com
comment but you can block them it's
bizarre I'm just like well thanks for
sticking up for the person that's making
making the content but um they ask you
on Facebook and Instagram if this person
creates another account would you like
to block that account too I'm like well
yeah yeah I don't want to deal with the
same thing but with a different name
this is stupid I'm like ah yeah the kids
that that run social media the big
companies are really useless
potatoes oh that's why they Shadow ban
you you're the people that made this
free platform that's helped me to sell
tick oh trust me it is ask gas or grass
Nobody Rides For Free but oh yeah yeah
making money giv giving
people free content is a you're not
giving them free content because they're
going to give their their email and
they're going to have information and
they're going to be followed right
they're so they're not doing it for free
second of all um they're using you
they're paying Pennies on the dollars
for your for
your uh content so you you they well
they're giving you no not really not
really yeah so it's it's give and take
and you have to follow their rules which
sucks but you have to follow their rules
about what you're putting on on there so
I've actually started a
patreon where people can come and see
unedited stuff so because there's
certain words like we've said un you
have to use un alive instead of certain
thing it's like just ridiculous like
it's just rid come on come we can we can
deal with it we can all get it done
people but as as a comedian like I mean
I've literally like I've literally been
looking at my photo album just like all
right well I've got to post something
and I'm just like scrolling my photo I'm
like well I got to post a video I've
edited stuff and then never put it out
as well like I I haven't overcome that
barrier of just like you just got to
throw it out there and just see what
sticks I was I was uh very uncomfortable
at the beginning of let just him sending
me stuff and saying him saying put this
out and I'm like well that's not even
the funny part of the joke right and
he's let's just do it and I'm like okay
and I had to follow my advice and that
as most most most resistant to change
are the first to be left behind so I had
to follow myself to not resist now I'm
resisting a little bit more because I
know a little bit more you know CU as
you grow you always learn a little bit
more so now you're like okay this is
where the funnyes should go there's the
funnies right here and then I teach him
a little bit too right so yeah what what
are you learning about social media cuz
I mean it's if you look at your YouTube
like you have great titles and
thumbnails and like the are there
certain clips that are are Styles like
what what are you learning here I'm
learning that thumbnails are like a
movie poster and that you have to spend
money on that movie
poster um and that's on YouTube I'm L
learning shorts are very important and
for and and get you the people to watch
the long form videos I'm learning that
uh the tags I haven't learned anything
about the tags I'm still confused by the
tags I'm learning that titles have to
catch them and give a little bit of
information of what's going on in the
thing but it has to be misleading as
well and I hate it I I I that like the
titling part I hate because I'm like
well that's not what happened and
they're like just do you talk about this
a little bit we have to use that I'm
like okay so yeah yeah and yeah like on
your most popular videos are like one of
them is like wrecked the front row or
something like there's like these action
words in there yeah yeah and then it's
like got a girl in it right and then me
with a shock face or something like that
yeah yeah it's yeah it's it's
interesting it just kind of but who who
hasn't who hasn't been to a movie where
they thought by the poster was going to
be about something else right right yeah
yeah yeah so it's the same thing but at
the same time you know I I would be more
I I remember being a kid and going to
movies and going oh the only funny part
was in the
trailer right right so
I don't know but it's fun making the
content like we're making travel Vlogs
we're making a a little bit talking
about uh behind the scenes and stuff and
we're just doing a couple videos with me
and my friends and just you know I'm I'm
enjoying making the content and building
it so that started in I think July or
something so we're slowly building this
whole this whole kind of Channel yeah
that's what I've that's what I've
noticed is it's gone from just standup
clips too like there are like you
reacting to certain things or yeah and
you brought your friend on for the most
recent one um like reacting to negative
comments about you and things so yeah
you're are you guys doing like almost
like um like a production team do you
have like production meetings and your
brainstorming ideas and different
variables on shows we do we do so we
film once every two months and oh wow
yeah and and we film for a day and we
get out about probably four or five
videos
and then we um we use the standup For
some long stuff so we're pro we're
probably putting out one long video a
week and three shorts a week so the
shorts are always
standup um and then the the Longs some
sort of I want to be able to I would
like to be able to put just take an hour
show and put it out every month so right
now it's going to be looks like I'll
probably put out one every two months an
hour every two months and and then also
shorter like 15minute sections like
today we put out I think a 15minute clip
so yeah well I mean every I watch both
your shows tonight and like each one
could have been its bless you were you
not happy with them no I I was I was I
was I was I had a lot of fun yeah first
show was kind of annoying I thought they
were a dumb
crowd I was listening to them to laugh
before I got upstairs I'm
like but you you would wouldn't know
that by watching you like it seemed like
that a little hot breath water for you
there buddy you guys make your own this
is uh this is Georgia Mountain spring
water fontas is the company and they do
like labels that's cool so yeah this is
in lie of sponsorship right now see
that's what I'm excited about is this
show I've been doing it for seven years
I had over 400 interviews with comedians
it's like oh money would be cool at some
Mone would be great wouldn't money be
nice but then you you know you're doing
comedy almost 30 years and you're like
oh I pop on social media after I fir
everyone that I thought could help me I
had to do it myself you know so I'm
asking you what should I do with this
show I think you should find a young guy
that helps you cut and know social media
mhm I think you should do that I think
you should I think you should um have
these conversations in different places
like pick a hey can I take you you for
lunch hey can I take you well how about
take them to great spots in Atlanta okay
so have have a restaurant sponsor you
where you you talk about the you do
something before the the the before the
interview you show off this you show up
they have this they have that and you
show it to the comedian
right so and now you take take those and
you turn them into Clips right so you
put out clips and then you put out the
full so so could almost even if there's
like a cool like hip put putt place or
hip bowling like something kind of like
a hot ones where you're doing two things
at once maybe but it's showcasing this
mic but okay yeah multitasking Beyond
because I've just been sitting down with
comedians talking about comedy for seven
years and I was like it'll go eventually
that's well it will but what what sep
separates and we talked about ear you
want you want to make this a show more
than a podcast right right so your show
will be the
clips you can still be a podcast take
that and do it and then and then it's
you got a couple like hey I need an hour
at your day half an hour for the
interview half an hour for you to do a
couple things with me film that do it
see it it's going to take I would use
some locals for the first one gotcha so
you can figure out the timing of it I'd
figure out
I would ke figure out the best things
for the best Comics like something
that'll that'll hey you want to do this
and I'm trying to think about
something maybe you know somebody that's
with the Atlanta Braves and it's it's
knocking balls you know hitting balls at
the baseball park or something like that
I me yeah yeah yeah maybe it's that's
what it is you get involved with the
Atlanta Braves and comedy or something
like and that's you know that's that's
what you do but it
um there are a lot of shows where it's
just two guys talking so how do you how
do you separate yourself from them M and
I don't know if any of this works I
don't know I don't know like this might
be the way this it might be this might
be the way and it just all of a sudden
clicks right um but you have to you have
to put out the shorts to get people to
go to the Longs gotcha yeah that's what
I've been trying to figure out with more
consistency with yeah the short form
stuff I'll put out the long form podcast
and the video but the the short form the
editing and sitting down and actually
doing that is um cuz I think I I think
I've come to grips with like I'm cool
with this show being the vehicle where I
find momentum and stand up is something
I just continue to do and continue to
get better at and develop at I I think
for a while I had an ego of like but I'm
a standup and I need to make sure that
stand up you know but at the end of the
day it's like I mean if this show is
what takes me to where I'm trying to go
then I'm fine with that yeah why yeah if
it helps you do something else yeah yeah
absolutely yeah yeah don't don't be uh
don't P pigeon hole yourself
don't don't just think okay this is it
but let you you have the ability
to to
um do whatever you want so maybe it's
you starting a patreon channel and you
get 100 50 to 100 followers and then
your friend these people that are that
love watching this that learn watching
this pay $5 to $10 a month to watch this
which is a cof or to but it it gives you
money to make the content mhm so
therefore the content gets better right
so I I app yeah I appreciate you sharing
those ideas because it is interesting to
see just the diversification of your
content has been really cool to see in
the evolution of it so it's thinking of
all right well there's one format you
can start to mix it in like you said
like an actual Channel yeah which is
interesting yeah you just yeah you got
time to watch I want to watch his travel
Vlog I want to watch him a standup I
want to watch how he ended up here I
want to yeah so have you ever considered
quitting comedy in your 30-year career
I'm sure but you never took it actually
seriously I guess of like I'm actually
done I I want to hear something dark
yeah I'll tell you dark I was going to
ensure the [__] of myself and kill
myself to leave money for my
wife really yeah like recently probably
within probably before the
pandemic cuz cuz I was turning I was
about I'm 52 now so I was about to turn
50 or something like that I'm just like
oh I got to I got to be concerned about
somebody else's so so I was just
like I was trying to figure out how to
how to like do it so she would get a
bunch money how how were you googling it
how seriously I I was just in a dark
place I was in a dark place and I was
like I was frustrated and
and um yeah and it wasn't just about me
but it was about me it was just like
what can I do to make sure people I love
or taken care of
because I was stuck at this medium To
Mediocre I was I was
struggling to get work I was struggling
so like what you know and I knew nothing
else so and what's funny is the
pandemic was probably the best thing for
me and let me sit back and re-evaluate
and take time off the road and figure
out see different things and not be
worried about you know just kind of
getting back to that when when you're 20
and failure is not an option but it's
it's not an option but it's the only
option you have to fail like you have to
fail somebody asked me tonight how do
you know what's too far and I'm like you
you don't until you fall off the edge
you don't know where the edge is until
you fall off and stand up I think the
people that are the funniest get into
trouble get find out like we've all gone
way too far but before before people
were taping nobody knew about it right
so now you can get into trouble and yeah
yeah but I don't know anybody that does
comedy with hate in their heart so I
hate when they come after I hate no hate
in heart and I but it disappoints me
when they come after comedians like
we're supposed to make you laugh at
something you never thought you would
laugh at well how do you get there where
it's to too too far too too you know man
it's it's it's crazy it's yeah but but I
was able to I was a during the pandemic
I was able to just shut down and and
refocus and then you know come out of
basically the pandemic what got you on
the other side of this dark thought or
why you just go through you go through
depression can clear up like I just I
just it was depression but it was things
were getting better and I could
see I could see that I could control
like I just did some things during the
pandemic and I was like okay I can see I
can see that there's a their way for me
so and then it took me till last I guess
that's about a year after the pandemic
right so to figure it out that I didn't
need anybody and you know that took me
the first three months and then I
remember I put out a uh and I I was
laughing at this cuz I was looking at I
just I put out with a company
called I put out a CD or something they
just and I just gave them a tape of a
show and they destroyed it they just
there it's never made any money they're
just a they're just garbage like they're
garbage or Garbage organization really
because they're producing a lot of stuff
dude what's the point you can do it
yourself then they're just going to take
your money for you I know that I've
never made a penny off them if they're
if they if there if I've never made a
penny off them there's guys that are way
below me that are probably owing that
money still oh oh so you paid them to
release it on there so you don't you
know so we want to do this with you but
here's the cost oh they just front the
cost that's all they do okay they don't
they don't pay for it and then you start
making money they just front the cost
and then you have to pay all the cost
back well my I gave them a show and
there was still cost I was like you
didn't film anything you didn't record
anything you just cut it up into a CD
and there's cost don't give and the
artwork is just garbage like they're
just a it's just garbage and come after
me I don't care you're garbage I mean
they're doing a lot like every time I
open social media they're producing who
they produc yeah but
you have to believe in yourself and you
have to put
out you have to if somebody's offering
to do something for you what's their
gain so that if their gain is putting it
into their catalog to say we've got all
these people but did those people make
money like did they make money like
here's I'm I'm not going to mention the
company because I don't want to mention
I did a special and it ended up on
Amazon Prime and now another company
owns it and Amazon Prime still owns it I
could not put those clips out without
them being flaged H because they owned
it even though they just bought it off
another company that I never I I I I
received $1,000 for my [__] Amazon
Prime like this is the kind of stuff wow
this is why you get depressed because I
don't I don't come from money I don't
come from a Showbiz family I don't come
from America I have to figure all these
things out on my own and sometimes
you're stuck you're just stuck spinning
and you you got to you got to you you
got to figure out a way put your your
own stuff out well the way you put your
own stuff out is you you tape it you
tape these shows and you don't do crowd
work you do you and you find one minute
pieces under a minute pieces and you put
them out right don't save anything
nobody saves anything for a late night
talk show anymore nobody sh saves
anything for a special you put it out
and then you just keep on writing you
keep putting it out and now you've
you've maybe earned some money off of
off of that stuff you put out because
shorts does pay if you have you know you
got to get to a certain amount amount of
followers but they pay um and and you
can put that money into doing your and
then the word special is just overused
like a maniac right so you put out your
hour yeah you put out your half an hour
you put out your 15 minutes but if you
can get if you can get 200,000 views on
on on YouTube you know that's 200,000
people that's 200 you know it's you
don't need you don't need to give
everything up
because you're not giving any of those
there's you're not giving a company such
as ble bleed we'll just put we'll just
put bleach in there yeah yeah yeah okay
you don't you're not giving they're not
you're giving them everything you're
giving them ownership of
you
and the new world is you own everything
the new world is you figure out how to
get the money to to be the owner and how
to to build it it's and there's there's
guys out there that that'll record you
for $200 that have great sound great
lights great cameras it's it's there
there there's no excuse you have to do
it but you also have to find a
partner that um that can help you and
that might cost that might cost you some
money um I I went into
um business with this people and I form
this production company and I pay a
little higher percentage than what
people would be surprised at and my
friend said well you can say no and make
0% of 100% of zero mhm or you can make
60% of a lot which you want and trust me
you don't need for ownership you need
ownership and you need to figure out how
how to do uh you you need to be able to
do it you need to be able to put it out
and that money has got to be coming back
into your pocket and it's got to be
putting money in your pocket touring
it's got to be putting money in your
pocket by by being seen on the internet
and and weirdly enough the internet is
now apps right it's now going to Roku
and watching it on different apps right
so there's many different places to sell
it don't don't be tricked by the
GateKeeper what what about sorry guys
I'm not trying to be depressing I'm just
trying to I'm just I just I I want you
to do you the world will keep the world
will
keep moving right the world is is kind
of overwhelmed with content it's like
saturated but the cream will rise to the
top and and people will will uh figure
it out that's why I can't even imagine
like starting comedy Now where these
these like young Comics are like open
mics trying to get a crowd work clip but
also figure out how to do a misdirect
like they're trying to figure out even
how to like move the mic stand but also
oh I got to film this to go viral well
that's there's the problem you don't
when you first start out mhm you don't
sorry sorry nobody there is no such
thing as an overnight sensation in
comedy yeah dud I love when they say
Matt R it's an O overnight sensation and
Matt R has been working his balls off
since he was 16 years old y mhm so no
no everybody everybody puts in their
time so so you think the young Comics
should just focus on getting good and
having something worth sharing not
trying to share whatever yeah cuz hey
hey what do you know to write a joke and
then come back to it in four months is
it the same definitely not the first
time he did he just like oh that was
[__] right and you thought it was
brilliant when you did it and then
you're like oh then you just reform it
and reform it it's it's it's art art
takes time yeah but you would when you
were featuring you would do crowd work
and you actually you had gotten fired
from gigs for doing crowd work the thing
that you're now yeah I know going viral
for yeah I know you got to yeah yeah it
was different though it was different
and so different it was just was
different it was so I it's it's and it's
the other thing is clubs are different
now clubs used to be partners with the
comedians they built you to a certain
point right they they were the clubs
were so strong with the talent that
people showed up if they showed at the
comedy club they were going to get a
good show it might not be for them but
they knew they were getting a good show
because the way it was curated was it
was Talent now it's what can put butts
in the seats and I hate to say it but
some some some Tik Tok kid sells half
the seats and then half the seats go to
people that want to see comedy you're
now you're going to have you're going to
have half the crowd that say I never
want to go back to that place again that
was the worst they don't know who the
the Tik Tok kid is right so they're four
walls they're basically four walls and
and we're now taking all the
responsibility on oursel to make sure
that this the seats are all sold whereas
before they had a marketing team they
worked with you to make sure that got
pressed they may worked with you to make
sure people knew you were coming you
know you have to do that all yourself
now you have to be the business so it's
just it's tough excuse my
language at this point yeah well I yeah
but it's yeah there's nothing like it
stand up that's why you'll never stop
doing it
yeah right right he might right he might
rework the [__] script yeah oh maybe
I'm not supposed to do this and and
there's no more powerful word word the
know in in Show Business hey do you want
to come do the show for 200 bucks no
Suddenly It's 500 and gas being paid so
Amen to that yeah well Ian bag where can
people uh follow you where where would
you like them after this or do you have
any closing
312 follow me on ways
uh uh just get it's Ian bag.com follow
me on Ian bag at uh on YouTube Ian bag
at Instagram
uh yeah it's Ian bag all over the place
so uh I like in even though I'm in a
fight with Instagram right now I like it
I like it the best YouTube's fantastic
you're basically building a television
network here there of your own uh it's
it's yeah they're all great they all
have good things they all have bad
things like I love watching Tik Tok I
hate posting there but I love watching
Tik Tok I haven't gotten into it I have
an account but I don't I don't get on
there at all like a [__] yeah well yeah
they spend a lot of money to make sure
that algorithm
is yeah don't be tricked by the
algorithm so but follow Ian follow us
too subscribe to our YouTube channel too
yeah subscribe subscribe like and
share I back thanks for being on H thank
you buddy awesome two white guys high
five high breath